ich zeige euch heute mein lieblings
Pasta Rezept für zu Hause und wir das
ganz einfach nachkochen können und ja
ich bin ziemlich anfängerkoch erstmal
Nudeln in Wasser geben habe ich mit
einer Pfanne gemacht dann Tomaten klein
schneiden Cherrytomaten lecker lecker
dann die Nudeln abgießen und erstmal ein
bisschen herunter drehen schön Butter in
die Pfanne dann die Tomaten da rein die
Cherrytomaten dann bisschen würzen mit
Pfeffer und Kräuterbutter dazugeben
Spinat auch dazugeben Mozzarella schön
Kleinstein und ebenfalls dazugeben und
dann sieht das schon super lecker aus
dann nehme ich hier mein Selbst
gekauftes oder das habe ich selber
gekauft und du das ebenfalls ein
bisschen zu und dann noch Sahne und dann
schön umrühren und boah das sieht schon
so lecker aus dann kommen jetzt einfach
nur noch die Nudeln hinzu und schmecken
lassen
einfach wirklich richtig richtig lecker